[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys adam welcome back to the leia
high pen show powered by
icon plus so as always it is powered by
openplus a really quick news
announcement for you so
iconfi has surpassed 25 million dollars
in capital commitment
so they're really looking forward to the
launch of the very first
all-in-one digital asset platform built
on icon and the release is actually
coming um
on in january 2021 so stay tuned for
that that will be great
i want to say thank you as well to my
sponsors block buy so i actually use
them to earn up to eight point six
percent
interest on my usdc so ufcc is a stable
coin it's pegged to the us dollar
um and you can get up to 8.6 interest
and if you think about everything that's
going on this year
um interest rates are practically
negative actually in in europe they
pretty much are
um so i think the bank of england is
like 0.01 so
that's pretty insane so i'll leave the
link for that if you guys are interested
um and before i bring in my brilliant
guest um
i want to say a quick thank you to coin
phillips so um they are doing some
incredible work across the states to
push bitcoin mass adoption
they have now 1 200 um bitcoin atms
providing access to everyday
people um so again i'm going to leave a
discount code for you you can get um i
think it's about 10
off um transaction fees so that would be
great so
joining me today we have a pretty
interesting topic um i guess it's kind
of like
politics meets bitcoin two of my
favorite kind of things
put together so joining me today is
isaiah jackson the author of
bitcoin and black america and the
co-host of the gentleman of crypto let's
bring him in how are you doing doing
great oh man glad to be here glad to be
talking with you absolutely
yeah i'm super excited to talk to you
because you have like i said
two of my most obsessed topics you've
sort of
delved into politics and everything
that's going on there and then you've
delved into bitcoin so
i want to go back a little bit before we
get into black america and everything
that's going on there
i want to understand a little bit about
bitcoin and how you
landed on it what is it about bitcoin
that caught your attention
oh man so i i think um you know i lived
through the 2008-2009 financial crisis i
was in college at the time
um that really piqued my interest with
finances uh even though i was
you know more in the tech uh you know i
was in college so i was learning
computer science but
that's what picked my financial interest
because how can an economy just fail
like this
you know we're american what's going on
um and when you're in college you're
already broke you go from like broke to
broken
like jesus i'm working i'm not going
anywhere for like three months so
um that peaked my interest and then i
was introduced to bitcoin by a friend of
um and the best part about you know that
introduction was it came from the
financial industry he worked for
uh uh i don't want to say the name but
he worked for a financial industry place
yeah and um
they spoke about bitcoin but he didn't
understand it and since i was in the
uh computer world he was like you might
understand it better it's sort of this
like techie thing so you just
pass it off to me um and i ran with it i
watched some videos from max kaiser i
saw how the winklevoss brothers
you know how they were invested uh and i
think i came from it's two ends of the
spectrum i think people getting bitcoin
either so rich you can take a chance
or you're so poor you're like what do i
have to lose that's where i was
i was a teacher you know our teachers
don't really get they're notoriously
underpaid
i was like what do i really have to lose
let's see what this bitcoin thing is and
it started out as
i want to make money but because we had
a bear market um
introduced me to the technology i was
like okay well i need to focus on this
see it and then the picture broadened up
from there and
i think that's what really helped me i
had two almost three years where i
didn't speak about
bitcoin which is funny because you know
some people
two weeks and they're already experts so
yeah so it took some time but that was
my start and then uh getting to where we
are today
yeah i think i think that's so
interesting that you make a really good
point you know people are either
super rich that they can take that
chance um i think that was the
winklevoss brothers that's their story
and then someone you know
like herself who's like well i i that's
the only thing i can do it just sort of
it sort of makes sense
so but what was like that rebel moment
whereby you thought okay this is
actually revolutionary was it i mean did
you even have one are we just sort of
thinking well you know
we've had the financial crisis anything
will be better than than what we have
now
um well when i started reading more
financial things and i started
understanding
um basically how the federal reserve ran
everything um
jekyll island reading that book um real
that
really opened up my mind to the point
where i was saying well the system as a
whole
is built for us to lose because of
inflation it started down that whole
path and i was like if there
is a solution bitcoin would be it
because it's a scarce asset
it's digital people can use it for the
future i got laughed out of the room so
much
i actually use that as a that was the
light bulb moment was when i was telling
people about it
and they were laughing and they were
like what are you talking about this is
so to me an idea is not big enough
unless people are laughing at it at
first
if everybody accepted it i'm sort of an
outsider i sort of i probably would have
ran away from
well everybody's on it now i'm gonna do
my own thing um so
because it was you know a time period
where people didn't understand it they
kind of laughing out the rooms or they
didn't
even want to pursue it that that was a
light bulb moment and i think that
happened
it was an event in charlotte 2014 i went
to it was a financial
uh like urban league or something like
that a lot of black professionals a lot
of rich people
and no i was wearing this exact
sweatshirt as a matter of fact
okay nobody knew what i was talking
about nobody gave me the time of day
yeah most people were like well that's
cute it's a digital collectible
type thing so i think that was the light
bulb i was like i'm on to something
because none of them understand it
and you know uh now here we are now
they're begging for bitcoin
yeah i guess they sort of thought it was
like this weird nerdy tech thing and
it's just like
sit back in your box you know what kind
of thing yeah and especially
i mean i know how i look black guy
dressed kind of regular
they think of bitcoin it's like a nerdy
white dude in his mom's basement that's
how it was
um because that's what they thought they
were like isn't it
some techy nerdy thing in silicon valley
yeah i was like no it's for everybody
but
it started that way so good i'm glad we
was pretty user friendly
so then that's really interesting okay
so you said like it started off with
this perception of this nerdy white guy
in his mom's basement or whatever
however you want to put it but
then when were you like hang on this
could be good
for black america like at what point i
don't want to get into like
we'll get into like the problems that it
could solve but at what point did you
make that kind of realization and that
connection and then with that in mind as
well do you think that the current
financial system
do you think that it is how do i put
this sort of do you think it
it's worse on the black community than
it is on the white community or do you
think
it's just terrible as it is as a whole
and you're just there you know doing
what you can do for your own community
uh well i like to use the quote as far
as economics go in america
if america has a cold black community
has a flu
and if there is a problem of course it's
there
it affects everybody but because of the
systematic uh financial racism
discrimination
whatever you want to call it all of that
has happened it's documented it's
historical
many people have written about it um
because that has happened we have seen
the numbers
and you uh you have a black community
with less savings uh less earned income
things of that nature the biggest thing
for me was because this affects us all
of course bitcoins for everybody but i
targeted the black community for one
family but of course also community
because if anybody can understand
uh something that threatens the status
quo and being misrepresented in the
media like bitcoin was
should be the black community pretty
pretty common i mean we've seen welfare
queens and
and lazy black man on every you know me
on every telecast
media that we've seen we know this so
at what point do you decide what do we
have to lose let's let's try something
different
that came for me uh around 2014 2015
um you know sort of the ferguson riots
happening and people like what's the
solution and i'm like
you know i don't really know but i know
it has to start with economics i mean
everything you're talking about you can
march all you want we've done everything
i always like to tell people whenever
you're on many forums we've had a black
president we have black ceos we have
black millionaires we have like
politicians we have
black people in power we still have the
same basic
um median income as 1968.
so what does that mean economically
nothing has been solved and i think you
start to see that
i mean even with some of the little i
don't get to political start but some of
the political parties that have won
the presidency here some of the black
groups are trying to understand why
they're just like ah we don't need you
now it's no more you don't have any
leverage there's no economic foundation
so once i saw that
and i saw bitcoin was there that to me
was the ultimate answer
yeah that's really interesting because i
you know everything that's been going on
this year with blm there's been a lot of
um
significant black people ice cube for
example you know
talking about um you know it starts with
um not so much it's not necessarily
money in itself but it starts with kind
of like a basic understanding of
business a basic understanding
of economics and how to as a community
better to sort of
you know leverage this newfound
knowledge and and then
move forward right um so with
so so with how so how do i explain this
okay so
how would you then sort of put that
forward though because i often find that
it's so hard just to get the average
person to tap into bitcoin and say okay
this could help
but how do you get that message forward
do you think it's just a matter of
you know we've tried everything else
what else have you got to lose is that
kind of the idea
uh to an extent but also education and
leading by example
uh i like to tell people that my own
family laughed at a lot of the ideas i
had with bitcoin until i moved to
beverly hills and then all of a sudden
it was like what's that bitcoin thing
you're talking about
so i mean leading by example not just on
the money standpoint but just lifestyle
change
seeing me start businesses a lot of
networking uh touring around the country
being able to have a network of people
in a community to me that's so uh
close-knit uh bitcoin you really can't
break it up we
started a currency from scratch i mean
that's never been done before so
uh i think if you leave by example and
you show people this they'll see that
bitcoin is a better answer than what
they have and most people they don't
even argue with it anymore they're like
all right we understand
it's going to be great um you know but
how do i get into it i think that
argument is kind of over
um last the last boron
we had a lot of people who still
questioned it was like the bubble pop oh
what are you going to do now i think
anybody who survived from 2017 to now
wow before that um should have any say
so
to tell somebody like look this is not
going away and uh if somebody's on the
fence
in my opinion i'm starting to go the
satoshi route if you don't get it by now
i don't have time to explain he said
that 10 years ago i'm saying
in 2020 only because there's no way you
haven't heard of it if you want to learn
then learn but if you just like nice it
still won't work
kind of now you're getting left out of
the room
it's so funny because i'm producing like
a lot of content daily and i'm on tick
tock
and people talk about crypto twitter
being absolutely hectic and toxic and
mental
but i've got to say crypto tick tock is
mental i get people daily
call you know saying bitcoin is a scam
that's a ponzi scheme
so i'm going on a rabbit hole and i
probably shouldn't
yeah no i know but it's so funny because
like we often say oh come on i think
everybody sort of knows at this point
that it's not a scam but there are still
people out there
that really believe this thing is just
the biggest load of rubbish
but i want to go back a little bit and
understand a bit more about you and your
experience
and because i think you know for you to
make that connection between bitcoin and
black america
you've obviously had to have some kind
of experience which made you feel like
okay we need something
so i'd like to just go into your
background a bit and know a bit more
about
issues that you face and how you think
okay you know what maybe
it could be different uh so
in theory um before 2017 in theory i
always thought to myself
group economics works because in larger
cities
uh you have chinatown yeah koreatown you
have
a little ethiopia you have these
economic communities that help each
other live each other up
and because they're insulated they don't
have as many uh of the social problems
like you might see what police or we
might see
with politicians we don't really own
that in the black community
a lot of uh our stores are owned by uh
people outside of our community
a lot of our money goes to outside of
our community so group economics was
something
in theory i thought of in 2017 when i
moved to la
in 2017 i saw it in real life and i was
like this works i mean
i'm walking through koreatown and half
the stores are in korean they don't even
care that you can't read what the store
says because
their group economics works they hire
their kids
their kids working in the stores they
send them to college they become the
doctors that they use later it's it's
it works so it you know in practice what
i said was well
in my opinion it's still sort of bad in
this current system with bitcoin though
that value
uh increases over time so we can
practice group economics combine it with
bitcoin
blockchain technology as the basis that
to me would solve most of our problems
and i ran with it that's why i wrote the
first book big one in black america
saw what happened after covet and
decided to write the second book bitcoin
black america the second edition which
is
alpha pre-order now so the reason i did
all of that
was because of that premonition i was
like what do we what are we even talking
about like if we're gonna do
something that works in our community
group economics has proven to work
solo millionaires and a couple
billionaires doesn't mean anything oprah
will smith and lebron can't be
representation for those
that's not what it's like so uh it has
to be sort of a group effort because it
works
and we have a global community and i
think we should take a shot at it
bitcoin is probably the easiest one yeah
what i think is actually really cool
is that bitcoin is so much more than
just like an investment or a
currency there's a kind of mentality
that comes with it so i feel like
if you're going to implement bitcoin in
this community and you're going to push
for it
you're sort of adding more whether it be
like the idea of taking personal
responsibility
not relying on the government um and
sort of just i guess it also brings like
a mentality of like innovation
um and just tech in general and tech is
the future so
it's like um it's more than just bitcoin
isn't it it's a home
it's really a rabbit hole for real
because what you find out when you learn
about bitcoin is
okay well what's this cryptography stuff
okay well what's this
algorithm okay well what's the math you
have to do okay what's the history of
money what's the history of governments
all of a sudden you're learning things
that make you more independent then you
start changing your mindset on how
things work
because when you actually have free
money what ends up happening is people
understand
they're not connected to the state
anymore they're a sovereign citizen
that opens up more i know people that
have gotten into bitcoin also they're
like
i should start growing my own food now i
should probably find a water supply
i should probably figure out ways that i
can uh learn about how to build things
because i may have to build my own
houses
all these things that leads you down
this road and it's inevitable it just
takes some time
yeah and i as well as that you know it's
what kind of gets me though
is i'm always trying to figure out the
best way
to explain it to people right because
bitcoin's not always going to be
twenty four thousand dollars we're
always going to be in a ball run um you
know and actually
my mum today brought bought some bitcoin
um
so i was also very exciting but she
really was you know really
yeah exactly it's all very exciting um
but she's only really sort of
extra sold and my brother's extra sold
simply because
we're in a bull market so what do you
think some of the biggest issues are
going to be
when convincing black america that
bitcoin could actually
be of value to them um so two
main things for people who have a
uh a low time preference meaning that
they're in this for the long term
then unless you bought bitcoin uh this
past week
zero people have lost money everybody's
in profit so
the volatility aspect of it is if you
just wait i mean it's so simple it's
complex it's just about a big point in
weight
everybody's because the market's built
that way and the value comes from
a strong network of holders who will
never sell and that is happening now
second thing i would say is for
detractors who say okay i don't really
like bitcoin i don't want to use it you
know um or they just don't understand it
one of the things you have to let happen
is you have to let them lose money
and i know that's harsh but let them buy
the top
let them see a bear market for three
years and then come back again
and then they see nothing happen because
people who bought in 2017 or 17 000
are like oh well that's over you know
what i mean but they were dying inside
for three years
i've seen it this is the third time i've
seen it so in my opinion
just let it happen and to me losing
money is the best teacher
you gotta pay tuition at some point so
if you think you're just a lone wolf
who's gonna solve the market by yourself
you don't want any help go ahead and do
that but i know how many people have
lost thousands of dollars doing that and
some people when they
they need that so that's both ties to
the point
i want to talk a lot about victim
mentality because i feel like it's
something which
the bitcoin community tends to sort of
reject
just because generally speaking
obviously
um you know just because it's all about
like you know not your keys not your
coins take personal responsibility
everyone seems to be a bit of a
libertarian to some extent um
so when i was um like reading and
researching about your book and
everything
um one of the biggest things which kind
of got me was you know
how do we pull people out though like
how do we pull people out of a victim
mentality because
a lot of the time whatever community it
comes from you know whether whether it's
just any old person that's gone through
a difficult you know
life difficult life circumstances it's
really hard to pull people out
um so do you think do you you know i
know
you're obviously on your second edition
of the book but how possible is it
um to sort of give somebody a solution
because you know there's like they say
you can give somebody um a bit you can
get you know give someone a fish and
they eat the day or teach someone how to
fish and then they
eat the rest of their life so how likely
are you to be able to actually like
help them and really sort of i don't
know wake people up and bring them out
of that kind of
fatality well i start where my dad
started with me
he told me when i was young he's like
nobody owes you anything and nobody's
gonna help you
so if you start there you don't you
don't some people don't
agree with that though like we've we say
that again and again and some people are
still like no the government does owe me
something
nobody's he's especially weird
especially as a man
like when he told me that it hit me
because i was so young and i was like
what do you mean y'all help me all the
time you know me like my mom but as i
got older
you realize it's if you can't help
yourself uh at some point
you're always gonna be begging out for
help from somebody else and i hate the
victim mentality especially in my
community
when it comes to things that in my
opinion can be solved if you work at it
but most people don't want to do work
that's that's the only problem uh to me
if there's a solution that can be had
for different issues if we can get a
solution we should work towards that
but if you're gonna go and complain and
say hey please please help us please
help us
to me that's that's uh very weak and
those discussions are not
uh things i want to take part of so yeah
i'm not a big fan of the victim
mentality some of the things that's been
happening too
uh with a lot of social media is that
it's actually like
popular to be a victim everybody that
gets
something done to him is like oh my god
the worst thing ever and sometimes i
point out things that's happened to me
but
that's not gonna stop me i can't look my
children in the face and or my daughter
in the face and future children
or my wife and say oh man i could we
couldn't be successful because
the person out there stopped me like
that's that's so weak
to me and really as uh as somebody who's
growing up in a family
of entrepreneurs or people who stood on
their own i think that's kind of where
it came from even from my grandfather
owned his own bar
uh you know my father owns an insurance
company you know people have their own
businesses my cousins have uh clothing
lines you know
we've all been like you have to be able
to hold yourself up now we're all strong
so when i talk about the community or us
being strong as a community
help everybody by helping yourself
everybody wants this we all come
together
let's help each other so nothing will
happen to us but if you're not strong
yourself uh what exactly can you
contribute so
not having a victim mentality just
taking life head on living i mean
you only get one i'm not gonna sit
around and cry because something
happened
like it's it's just yeah i get through
it and you will have obstacles
just deal with it yeah i totally respect
that and i wish
more people had that mentality um i i
absolutely wish because you either find
you know
either you go through something really
difficult in life and then you're sort
of like okay well i don't have a choice
either i can sulk or i can pull myself
up
um or people just don't pull themselves
up and i wonder
um i wonder to what extent people can
pull themselves up
right all i'm gonna say is in this in
this day and age with the internet
everybody has a phone
everybody has access to information it
may take some time
but everybody can at least pull
themselves up to an extent i'm not
saying everybody can become a
millionaire but you can go
middle class if you get a skill learn it
over time you may have to eat ramen for
too much straight like i did
i mean i did that a few times training
bitcoin you may have to
not go out you may have to uh tighten
your budget up a little bit you may have
to
sit and focus and read for long periods
of time things people don't want to do
what i'm saying is there is a way out
but if it's harder than others i'm not
about to
say oh it's harder so i'm not gonna do
it you just have to do it um and i think
once people understand that and they
find ways like with big point crypto
to assist with with that mindset i think
it's a win-win so
once we get that monster uh a lot of us
already do is just a few that
don't the few that do have the victim
mindset they're the loudest so
that's why you're here yeah i mean i i
just think it's such a shame because i
share the exact same mentality as you i
think absolutely okay i wouldn't
have to be millionaires but i think
absolutely anybody can pull themselves
up from any situation i've seen too many
incredibly successful people come from
absolutely terrible circumstances and i
don't believe that it's entirely luck
like i just don't i think luck is just a
by-product of preparation
um so i mean this is kind of a really
interesting conversation because it goes
beyond
um bitcoin right because it's all about
you know improving yourself like you
said there's enough information out
there everybody's got a phone
everybody's good internet
um i'm just wondering how we really sort
of like
push that message home because
especially to the people who
don't really understand about bitcoin
i'm just sort of figure trying to figure
out like
how you know how like how that continues
to go how that looks in the next 10
years
um i don't know if you have like 10-year
kind of vision or anything like that
i mean this for generational stuff the
bitcoin i own i think i'll just be
passing down
um i had to you know 10 years out
uh 2030 i would say bitcoin will be the
reserve asset of
major corporations if not a country at
that point
we're already saying michael st larry's
about one and a half billion worth of
bitcoin
that is just the beginning trust me he's
gonna look like the smartest man in the
room next year and a bunch of ceos that
do not want to look back
they're gonna do the same thing so i
think we'll see that we'll see it more
uh
as a store value for large corporations
then we'll see maybe the stable coin
wars take off on top of that
because of course china has their own
others are building um so 10 years out i
think we'll see a very
a very different monetary system and i
think a lot of people will build on top
of bitcoin because it will be the
longest and strongest
um but other all coins will succeed the
same way companies succeed whenever
anything happens so
uh i think man this there's so much d5
is going on now we have nfts
who knows what will be ten years from
now i just can't wait for that
you know nine to ten year old that's
that 10 years from now
it's probably going to be the mark
zuckerberg or whoever oh that's crazy
okay you don't mean like creates an
incredible product so um that's what i'm
looking forward to
that's also why i'm doing a bitcoin
summer camp to teach kids trying to get
that pipeline because
this is the future and i can't wait i
mean hopefully we have some ai
in there somewhere with uh with the
crypto world
still young but yeah i think that's what
we'll see ten years from now
yeah i think i think it's insane to
think that you know we could actually
see a
well i don't know i see when we talk
about like bitcoin as a as a
as a global reserve currency i'm always
really just like unsure
you know when to work scalability and
this and that like as a store of value
i'm on board i'm there
um as like this global reserve currency
i just don't know
but what i'm doing it could be like four
or five countries to start using it um
but what i but what i do think i i
definitely think you know we are going
down that route um
you know no more cat you know there will
be a cash for society um unfortunately
for some
um yeah we are you know i always say
everything has gone digital right you
know i say like
dating has gone digital socializing has
gone digital and the way that we work is
digital the way we eat it's digital
everything is just digital so for me
it's just inevitable that everything's
going to go that way
um but what do you think you know like
there's a lot of talk about bitcoin
being
this political thing and people say it's
apolitical but i'm
really on the side of my is political
now i get why they say it's a political
because it's like you opt out right
but i feel like opting out is a
political choice
exactly i do too and you know as part of
the political process
i don't participate in these games this
is a circus whatever they
try to sell to people as far as these
groups i don't join groups i'm an
individual i have
things i like about certain ones and
then you can ask me that's about it
that's about as political as i get
but bitcoin being political is very
political i mean yeah
i don't know if people who know this but
the day my first book came out
president trump tweeted bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies are not real currency
you should not use it blah blah blah
oh really
uh it was uh july 11th uh 2019.
uh it's i write about it i write about
it in the second book because it was
crazy
no time before or after that did he
tweet about it other than the day my
book came out
so is bitcoin political i think it has
entered the political market i think
some of the regulations or regulators
who are trying to uh make a bridge with
bitcoin
uh have family members on themselves who
own it so it is getting into politics
and what we're starting to see is
the 25 30 year old who's been in bitcoin
for a few years when they become the
next politicians
they're going to work towards bitcoin
being a part of our our nation so
i think it is political i think it has
entered the political sphere i think
when people talk about
joe biden's second biggest donor uh
owning a crypto exchange
in china i mean that you can't ignore
that i mean
you gotta ignore that can you yeah it's
kind of factual so
bitcoin is intertwined somehow the
biggest thing is uh
nobody talks about it publicly not the
big big names um but i think it is
intertwined somehow and it will be a
race
uh for mining there will be a race of
course for big one to store value
and then whoever has the best cbdc that
that's kind of the nationalistic
approach to money moving faster
i want to talk a bit more about a book
because for those watching that don't
know i haven't read it yet so i plan to
read it over the christmas holidays
these are my
my well my plans drawing locked down
because things are just absolutely
terrible here
um so tell me about some like the
biggest challenges that you face
writing this book because how did you
did you sort of break down all the
issues that you've
experienced and all the issues that you
perceive to be um you know relevant in
black america and sort of talk about how
bitcoin can
solve those take me through it how does
the book look
absolutely so um the first book i start
off sort of uh memoir style just telling
my story
so that people can understand who the
writer is uh that i am a
regular guy who took the time to learn
about something interesting
and used it to create you know what i do
now um and i think that story kind of
opens eyes because they realize
oh you don't have to be a millionaire to
be successful you don't have to be you
know
some you know kid who got fifty thousand
dollars and just having to become a
millionaire you can work your way up
there's strategies for that so
it starts there it talks about um the
digital economy
introduces how bitcoin can start sort of
a circular economy if you
buy uh or invest in small businesses
whether black hole did not i
started with black owned in the book
because i want to understand that's the
backbone of any strong economy
small business and in our community if
we use bitcoin you can sort of opt out
of the current market so i go to that
point i talk about things such as
bitcoin and the black church
how we can use it as non-profit
donations as a store of value
um talk about how athletes sense black
athletes uh in the nba nfl
and uh and hip-hop have a lot of control
of social currency
if they adopt bitcoin if they talk about
cryptocurrency in the black community
that could be
good for us as far as adoption yeah so
i'll go into all of all of that in the
book talk about how
in other countries it could be adopted
but um you know in the second book i
take it up a notch
way more information but yeah those are
some of the ways i also talk about banks
i have a chapter called
book the fans uh but in the second
version it's called
yeah so and it's funny i actually did a
talk with a bank
and that was one of the guy's favorite
chapters so that goes through all of the
racial discrimination
just in the past eight years so it's not
like something in the i talk about
redlining i talk about racial
discrimination with loans
i talk about all that but i'm talking
about stuff that happened like eight
years ago
or three years ago so they're having to
do settlements for that for
uh black and brown people unfortunately
so we don't owe them anything
and that's sort of my argument with
moving into the bitcoin market so
uh that's what the book is about second
book has uh more information if i can
run through that real quick
yeah go for it yeah yeah i mean uh it
talks about bitcoin and black america
tour
how things have progressed in the
economy with you know covid and the
federal stimulus
uh bitcoins price movements talks about
privacy how to set up a truly private
wallet
because a lot of people it's not enough
now to just buy bitcoin you need to have
node which i'll talk about and describe
in there and you also need to have a
completely private wallet
which i also described as well i'll talk
about bitcoin in marriage but that's
which i think is a pretty spicy
chapter because of marriage what did you
say bitcoin in marriage yes
what is that what is that nobody
understands that when you go to court
now if you own bitcoin cryptocurrency if
you get a divorce
you have to you have to yeah you have to
understand those laws and regulations or
just getting half your wallet exactly
because i've actually had to consult
judges
where that's come up in court and they
have no clue what they were saying they
were like crypto
i don't even know so i talk about that
also discuss how if you
are married long term if you pass away
you want to be your
partner to know how to access your
private keys you don't just want your
people to go away
also return to wealth is built by being
able to hold it so if you're not able to
hold
bitcoin for the next hundred years what
are you really doing so
i talk about that um uh the laws in
different states
i talked about uh bitcoin as reparations
uh i thought i discussed
yeah wait i wanna i wanna just i was
asked the topic i wanted to actually
talk to you
bitcoin as reparations yes how does that
work
uh so without going too much in the
chapter the basic premise is
uh i don't believe reparations are ever
going to be given to black people
uh in the trillions of what they say
that's not going to happen
do you want do you believe that you guys
should get reparations firstly
i argue i argue that because reparations
have been given out in this country
two people who were disenfranchised
black people are owed
preparations there is a precedent for
what we're asking for the problem is
if you're asking for it to happen
there's two main things that i discussed
first of all the printing of money
print trillions of dollars debases the
currency get gets rid of the value you
think you just gave everybody
the second thing is you can either ask
for reparations or you can take them and
in my opinion
most of the corporations or banks or
whoever
that disenfranchise our community have
not purchased bitcoin or
are interested in purchasing bitcoin if
you can buy an asset
that they are interested in creating a
market value you can give yourself
preparations
and i to go through all of how that
could be possible and not just with
the value of bitcoin but business
enterprise blockchain technology all of
that
using that to your advantage in order to
get what you feel is owed to you
because i'm just going to jump in just
so i can like fully understand what
you're getting at so you don't believe
reparations will ever be given so
you're looking at bitcoin as a way for
people to sort of take their own
reparations because
you're buying bitcoin before the people
who um
you know you would hold accountable were
able to buy them um buy the bitcoins and
plus
it's a deflationary asset so it's likely
to go up anyways you're going to get
paid back in that way
so it's kind of like the reparations
which you never
were going to get basically is that the
way you look at it yeah exactly and the
money that was put into the country to
build it
one thing i also want to say to you i
don't necessarily think we won't get it
i just think that the work it takes to
get to that point
uh is a waste of time and what are we
waiting for i'm tired of
people going to capitol hill trying to
see
what more what more information do you
need i mean there is no more real
explanation you need
and i know people are working on that i
would encourage them to keep going
but that's not my that's not how i do
things i'm sort of impatient i guess
but there's a reason for that there
there's a time stamp on
when you can take advantage of something
that is life-changing and revolutionary
stop asking for reparations let's focus
on getting in the bitcoin market
or building a economy where we own it
because
the value you think that uh you're owed
will be given right back to you
because value is given to whoever
creates it and if we're in the value
market
that it's ultimately going to happen so
i believe in taking back what you think
is yours
not asking it and i'd rather ask for
forgiveness than permission any day
yeah i think that's really cool honestly
like i just i'm i'm
like huge respect i just think we're
doing is amazing i think just because i
just inherently despise everything
victim mentality related i love how
you're just there just sort of like
guys this this is it like here's your
answer like please you know you're just
there trying to educate people but
you know in terms of mass adoption then
um to what extent do you
um see bitcoin being integrated into
people's lives because you talk about
that integration you know you spoke
about church
but to what extent is this even possible
uh so i think one of the best ways to
intertwine this in people's life is
the advent of cash back rewards in the
form of bitcoin
and one of my main premises when i talk
to people is meet them where they
are so basically you do what you already
do and you can earn bitcoin if you
understand that long term this is an
asset you want to hold
so you have services not just feel
anything big or whatnot but
like fold out simple things you can
spend the wheel
on fold out you get free satoshis for
that there's
i mean it takes three seconds um you can
purchase goods on lolly
you can i mean every time i post face
post mates i get three and a half
percent back in bitcoins free money
for what i already do meeting with
people that have cash app already i
usually explain to them hey you already
have cash up the boost thing just
came about but i mean you could have
bought it in there and
you know it's it's a no-brainer to me
even uh services like black fire i mean
to me
it's kind of a no-brainer that instead
of selling your crypto
because that is a taxable event you can
actually put it up as collateral
get a cash loan which i actually have
just talked to a cpa
and you can actually write off if you do
it as a business the
um the interest rates that you pay uh
for your business so that's these are
things that people do anyway it's just
like just doing a bitcoin because it's a
more profitable market so
meet people where they are help them
basically establish
uh you know the mindset that bitcoin is
for everybody
and once they start to see that they're
like okay it's not for the rich is rich
and you can't buy a fraction of a
bitcoin i mean that was the biggest
question for probably three years
people didn't work by practicing like
man i don't have ten thousand or twenty
thousand
even now even now people still say that
and
uh once people realize that just meet
them where they are and uh i think
you'll have good success there
i think people get too caught up i think
people are so smart they get caught up
in
explaining the hash rate and the in
smart contracts nobody needs to know
that sometimes
nobody cares about electrical elliptic
curves dude nobody cares
talk to them
what about any other old coins then like
do you see any other alts as
number one a good store of value and
number two
because at the end of the day i guess
you know you can't you're not gonna be
teaching everybody to trade that's just
you know it's kind of just like buy
bitcoin and wait
that's good enough um but yeah do you
see anything
which could be just as a valuable um
like ethereum perhaps or
um well view uh the all coin market
uh sort of like i view uh bitcoin early
on as far as
utility now bitcoin i think it stands
alone by itself because it's an
anonymous creator you can't
confiscate it that is hard money that is
reserved asset
but i think of all coins sort of as
companies or as projects
that are using a token uh that can
become valuable for certain things so
ethereum
they have what i feel like is a novel
approach to try and create
decentralized apps i know all the attack
vectors i know security problems i know
what's wrong with ethereum
you know changing the ethereum classic
uh there's something like that with
every coin we saw
xrp today uh the sec may be coming out
to them
every single point that's not bitcoin
this can happen to but from a purely
company standpoint just trying to
innovate in the blockchain space
i like a few projects i mean it's fun
it's fun to have metamask
in in your browser and be able to buy
nfts
it's good that you can build you know
smart contracts do you own any nfts
exactly i'm sorry do you own any nfts
uh no i do not own any nfts i bought
them for other people but i don't
know um i have worked or started working
with uh somebody named micah johnson his
nft just sold 420 000. uh i'm trying to
put on an
nft show like a museum type show on
crypto boxes
so things like that are interesting and
i think when we talk about the
gamification
of the crypto world i think all coins
are better for kids
because if there's no like if you're not
giving them millions of dollars with it
oh you give them 20 bucks
it's good for them to play around with
use the blockchains are faster because
they're not cluttered
um a lot of times they have you know
things like uh
uh like narrow ring signatures some
people may like privacy
those features like that i think work
well but again none of them are bitcoin
to me because
it's unconflictable everything else i
think has that chance but
we'll see and you are the co-host of the
gentleman
of crypto so i want to know a little bit
more about this
um what do you guys talk about how where
did this come from
oh yeah so we're at episode 627
that's crazy it just felt weird
600 yeah yeah so we've been doing the
general crypto
pretty much every day for the last three
years okay
we started in 2017 and after
we would have started 2016 but we were
like did people even
people even tune in who knows so we just
went for it uh me and my
uh my co-host king um we were one of the
first
crypto shows that had live every day i
think we
definitely wanted the longest running
not sure but we had a live show every
day
we talk about news and updates and we
answer any questions that come in live
and we've been doing this since 2017. um
one of the biggest
aspects of it is it's not a huge show we
only have 4 000 subscribers
but everybody sticks with like a
close-knit community because
again to me long-term these are people
who probably don't use for networking
for the rest of our life who cares if
you have to do a 30 minute or hour-long
free show
when you get to network with people who
can help build for the future so
we decided to do that a lot of
opportunities came out of that and
uh fortunately you know it's opened up
doors that i didn't think would happen
because
i had never made a youtube video before
2017. that's one thing people don't know
i'm on interviews now and talk a lot now
but i just was anti-video for a long
time
in the bitcoin world because i was like
if people want to learn just go online
but then i realized
we need it no we need it people need to
hear you talking they need to see your
face and this is a real person behind
you
or behind it and uh it's work so far
again like i said not a huge show but i
think we get great information
so with all of this in mind you've got
your books and everything that you've
done
where's your family at with all of this
have you managed to sort of get them to
buy bitcoin
uh yeah i mean it's it's like 100
approval right now
but first it was scary you know i would
have plans about
maybe we could you know put you know our
money together about bitcoin back in the
day
uh yeah i could show you individually
yeah i had all these ideas and they were
just like no
there's nothing that convinces us uh
until
you know recently so now of course
everybody
in my family pretty much either owns
bitcoin or is is in the process of doing
it nobody even questions it anymore
i do have friends who are still on the
fence yeah the only reason
being on the fence is because the price
is so high unfortunately
i told them when the price was probably
i think 600
or 500 you know a long time ago but oh
you told them then
and they didn't i also gave a lot of
bitcoin away back in the day i remember
when i first started when bitcoin was
around 200 so
i would give i was giving away 0.1
bitcoin like it was nothing
because to me i was like that's 20 bucks
and you can get started you can do
something
i don't know how much bitcoin i gave
away back wait how are you where were
you buying it from back then
well back then i was i was getting it uh
actually through local bitcoins
yep and it was the easiest way for me
you could meet up meet people
by large amounts that was the easiest
way then through an exchange
i had coinbase for about six months i
would say back in 2015 but
got rid of them don't use them anymore
uh what happens
i think that's everybody if you know a
lot of bitcoin is they dunk on bitcoin
for good uh they don't hold coinbase for
good reason
um not reliable to me but yeah and now
i'm mostly uh swan
it's one bitcoin lowest fees in the uh
in the market so i like to use them but
yeah i mean now i don't buy much anymore
i just
kind of sit on it but yeah it was it was
a crazy time back then
and what if someone like so you said
that you know it's the price being
let's say you just call it 24k whatever
that your friends are just like oh it's
too expensive but what are the other
things like are they really do they
really get it like do they
sort of see it as like a cult and you
know something that they want to get
involved in
that's the thing like okay people have
seen me or read my books they're like i
get it
i know it works but i just don't know
it's an anonymous creator and you're
like
wasn't going to do anything
[Music]
i was like that's keeping you from
whatever like you know i heard this i
read the story
that bitcoin got hacked and i was like
no somebody got hacked
their bitcoin got stolen would you stop
using cash for bank got robbed
no so what are you talking about so they
still have these like
these these premonitions or intuitions i
would say that something bad is gonna
happen
because the biggest one i get now is so
is the government gonna shut it down
and i'll send them the link where they
literally the office of comptroller the
currency said
we're not shutting down bitcoin we are
not i'll send them that link and they'll
still say
but still do you think they could and
i'm like i don't understand you know
exactly
where these questions come from but it's
just people get scared not having the
knowledge
when they see that you can own and plus
not being used to being free
like some people they're scared
shitless what they think about the fact
that i get to own my own
i get to do this myself it's me they
don't even want that so
you have to understand that too this is
the first time ever unless you're
113 years old uh or 106 years old
you you haven't lived during the time
without the federal reserve
so you don't even know what it's like to
live in a system that's free enough
where you can just enter it
start today and then money is money well
this is what i was getting at earlier
when i was talking about victim
mentality because
people sort of just don't want that
responsibility like they don't you know
um because it's scary because it's not
just like it's not just a private key
it's like the sea prairies as well and
then it's like where do i put it and
then like
you know you you put it on ledger then
your database gets hacked
you know so like it's it's kind of like
a a real fear and i think the most
interesting thing for me about bitcoin
is like i obviously think it's political
but it's a mentality
so much and i just i just think that's
gonna be one of the real struggles when
it comes to
mass adoption because well it depends
what kind of mass adoption we see
because you know if you start having
everything in
in custody with custodians then it's
different but right now you know you're
trying to get people in and sort of
teach them about freedom i don't think
people want freedom to be honest
yeah some people don't even want to be
free that's the funniest part about this
whole situation is
you say it as if that's something
everybody wants and some people like
nope i would much rather have
such and such let them do it which is
fine which is you know some of the uh
backlash a lot of bitcoin people get is
oh why would you suggest products with a
third party
and like you do understand there's a
population of people that are never
going to be self-custody or
self-sovereign
and you know let people figure it out
but again
i don't really like to cuddle adults
that's why i like teaching kids because
i would rather show them really
but adults you get one chance with me if
you don't get it i'm
i don't care what big one for me i love
strength yeah i love teaching people or
helping people that want to be helped
i don't think i don't there's no
debating or
going back and forth um you know you
have your opinion just go with it if you
really
have that conviction then and then go
with it because i really
i really believe what i'm doing so you
better believe what you're talking about
because
i've been there yeah i'm with you this
kind of just like
it all links back to the same thing
because it just reminds me i was trying
to help a friend the other day with her
work and i was trying to sort of be like
you know
you really need to use social media
leverage it like this like for me i
think tik tok is just like
an incredible innovation for um online
creators
and i was trying to really help her and
she was like i'll do it tomorrow i'll do
it tomorrow and she didn't
and then last day i'm done no more
you're not a child like i'm not coddling
adults as you said
yeah exactly you know you know i told
you that's all that matters
you can't never ever say i didn't tell
you but the only complaints i really had
are people saying why don't you tell me
about more
so if you have any reservations that's
really the only complaint i really ever
had
yeah 100 and just finally i saw you
tweeting today um about the xrp news i
just wanted to get your thoughts on it
you don't have to throw yourself in a
fire
so you're you're welcome to sort of say
no i'm not going to comment too much
we'll go for it if you have any thoughts
yeah let's say the xrp buy are we going
to get it well i think it's
sort of a non-starter because they front
ran the news by saying
the sec is going to do this yeah let's
go to the front running
uh which i guess was smart on their part
just to sort of
beat it to the punch uh one thing i've
said since 2018
actually to get earlier than that is
that at any point xrp could be
considered a security and it's over i
mean what happens is
if they make the claim that it's a
security they can go back and forth they
can argue the highway test they can say
they need to be new standards doesn't
matter
i think exchanges won't take the risk
they'll just de-list xrp
and then what happens then now he's gone
and to me i don't see a real use case
i know it's pre-mined i know there's a
people that hold it it's not for me but
for speculative traders
do you thing i don't i don't really stop
anybody from anything that they want to
do
but i do if i consult people tell them
that
that's not for me so this news is sort
of hyping people up but i'm just trying
to remind people that yeah this could
happen
um at any time and especially we've seen
that in ico market they were smacking
the ico market in 2019 and this year so
yeah it could happen um he's going to be
careful
yeah i think um you make an interesting
point i mean brad garland house was the
one to come out straight away
um and blow the lid off the story and
sort of just say okay we're getting sued
um but it'll be interesting to see what
happens i mean i i
i tweeted today that i i do feel sorry
for those holding xrp but those holding
xrp you think this is great so that's
also cool
um i mean some of them were saying if we
get through this
the price will really go to the moon
because it'll be
and i'm like all right i understand
that's you know that's fomo that's
emotion but just looking at data metrics
not something that i i tend to uh pay
attention to
yeah i'm with you okay so just finally
then
tell us what are your last words where
can people find you somebody has
actually put in the comments can you
leave a link
to the book so send me a link afterwards
or you can put the link in there
in the comments so where can people find
you uh yeah so uh you can find me on
twitter at bitcoinsay
you can find me on instagram at bitcoins
a llc
you can find me at
bitcoinblackamerica.com
and uh if you reach out there uh the
book bitcoin of black america and
the second edition are available uh so
working on that now
and uh the gentleman of crypto on
youtube monday through friday at 10 a.m
eastern
well i want to thank you so much for
coming on i think what you're doing is
absolutely incredible it's right up my
street i hate victim mentality
and i really think education knowledge
understanding
um is everything people need i think you
know
everything sort of starts and ends at
the education system i think the
education system is so broken it doesn't
teach you entrepreneurship
um so the fact that you're pushing that
to help your own community i think is
fantastic i
absolutely love it so thank you so much
for joining me today
thank you for having me glad to be here
guys don't forget to tune in
next thursday 12 p.m est we'll see you
[Music]
[Applause]
then